hey guys Thor the dark world is hitting
theaters I had the chance to see a sneak
preview and it kind of rocked Thor was
hammering crap natalie portman was
looking all natalie portman like and me
like eloped but it wasn't always all
box-office gold for Marvel there were a
number of Marvel inspired adaptations
and were pretty forgettable let's take a
look at some Marvel misfires
so as far as bad Marvel goes you know
about daredevil Elektra the ghost riders
we're talking deeper cuts today and
since I just saw Thor I want to talk
about Thor's first live-action
appearance opposite the Incredible Hulk
in the Incredible Hulk Returns
The Incredible Hulk Returns the TV movie
from the 80s that is cheesy and terrible
Thor looks like he got his hammer at
Home Depot back then the Hulk also
shared the screen with daredevil at the
very worst it's a tie with Ben Affleck's
daredevil so we'll just give that one a
pass we couldn't do this episode without
talking about the Punisher you've seen
Ray Stevenson and Thomas Jane but I want
to talk about the first one
Dolph Lundgren aka Ivan Drago as the
Punisher they're good to be punched this
movie is so depressing it's like a
battle between the awesome body count
and brutality versus Dolph Lundgren's
monosyllabic performance not a sweater
we're having for this time you're
supposed to meet me here four hours ago
every day the children of God is gonna
cost you money where is the dope coming
into the dope I fear we may go our whole
lives without seeing an iconic Punisher
and that just may be our punishment take
that message to your people guys before
marvel's agents of shield there was Nick
Fury agent of shield I'm sorry about
clay Nick but it looks like hydras
trying to send you a message
looks like I heard it that's right
this 90s TV movie is a real thing it
starred David Hasselhoff as Nick Fury
Donna be you've been kissed with the
kiss of death personally I think
Hasselhoff would have been great in the
Avengers if they wanted to make the
movie utterly ridiculous an electronic
lock ticket oh there it is I thought I'd
left it in my other patch let's talk
about a particularly infamous Marvel
misfire the Fantastic Four from 1994 hey
you guys you guys don't you think this
is just a little too easy huh yeah I
love walking with Reb this movie was
written shot edited and then never
released shelved that's because it's the
worst the thing at such a creepy monster
face he looked like leprechaun Human
Torch looked like a cartoon and dr. doom
looked like he got his costume from a
Halloween store what do you mean all I
compared the 1 million dollar movie with
the subsequent 90 million dollar
Fantastic Four's not much worse you did
clobberin time here's one you've
probably heard of but may not have known
it was a Marvel movie Howard the
it was the first attempt at a Marvel
theatrical release since Captain America
serials from 1944 I just can't resist
your intense animal magnetism huh
the movie was so bad that it became a
punchline for bad movies holy crap with
a colossal failure like that it makes
sense that Marvel didn't really get its
footing into like 15 years later it's a
bird it's a plane no it's a duck
next is Captain America no not Winter
Soldier this is the 1990 version instead
of Chris Evans we have Martin Salinger
is the president thanks this is JD
Salinger's son people his dad wrote
freakin Catcher in the Rye that has no
bearing on this and does not help this
low-budget direct-to-video movie and now
I send our tortured soul stressed speak
for yourself
it's up
how is if one awful direct-to-video
Captain America movie wasn't bad enough
how about a crappy double feature of
Captain America TV movies the girls
where are they in a room under
number-two stack there all right where's
Brackett he's gone
show me where his office is one of the
only bright spots is the appearance of
Christopher Lee Lord of the Rings
Saruman as the evil Miguel you didn't
expect to fool an old jungle fighter
with a boomerang trick like that did you
doesn't matter general there's nowhere
to go unfortunately this be double
feature needs to be dropped into Mordor
Oh
Wow you've come a long way marvel
which one of these stinkers do you on a
see most leave an answer in the comments
section below best answer get the screen
junkies t-shirt by the way we recently
passed 1 million subscribers we're super
excited about that thank you so much and
as a special thanks we're gonna dedicate
our Thanksgiving episode to you guys
we're gonna answer your questions and
read your comments so what do you want
to know something about screen junkies
do you have a question about honest
trailers do you want to know what Nick
Mundy's favorite breakfast cereal is
leave your question in the comments
section below if we use it we're gonna
send you a screen junkies t-shirt thanks
for watching I'm how rudnick hit me up
on Twitter bye bye hey screen junkies if
you like my voice how about clicking
that big subscribe button then huh